[Music]
hello
and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for cowboy
i am spencer j gilbert that's joe starr
we're going to watch the honest trailer
for cowboy bebop give you our behind the
scenes thoughts go into a little more
depth in detail
if you stick around after that we're
going to watch some deleted scenes we're
going to respond to some viewer
questions and comments
and we're going to tease next week's
honest trailer joe did i forget anything
no that sounds like a party oh yeah
let's get it started
uh light them up if you got them we're
talking cowboy bebop um
which as we say in the trailer was uh
your gateway anime into the hard stuff
and that was certainly true of me or
really toonami as a whole
it was the thing that you know they
lured you in with adult swim
they lured you in with you know even
baby's first anime like like dragon ball
z and stuff like that and then
and then cowboy bebop and then you're
off to the races what's your what's your
cowboy bebop history joe
uh that that whole adult swim era
is actually uh how i started hanging out
with my wife
uh my wife uh because we were um
we would just hang out and watch uh
bebop and fullmetal alchemist and
inuyasha and
that whole block on wednesdays i think
it was and so that was like our weekly
uh thing where we just uh hung out and
smoked cigarettes like cool kids
and uh and watched our anime instead of
doing homework which is for squares uh
indeed it is and yeah and that's i mean
you've gone even deeper than me
we uh we share a hulu account and i see
on there like
every other show to keep watching is
like you
you beautiful princess moronico or
something
like wow joe you're just going for it
we're watching a show called
uh tor usually watches something and
then i'll come in on like episode eight
and i'm like i like it too
and then she has to start over um
because that's that's her life that's
what she has to deal with but we're
watching a show called demon slayer
right now which is
actually really rad and you should look
at it well there you go let's talk about
demon slayer
we're talking about bebop which um to me
doesn't i mean it feels
obviously it looks like an anime but
it's i don't know
it's definitely not aimed at kids or
like teenagers i think this is like a
very adult
show in revisiting it um like it's
succinct it respects your time
it's just one season there's no filler
yeah but it avoids so much of what i
think we def
and look i'm entry level as hell so
everyone's gonna come in here
in like a second and be like talk about
space harlock you monsters but
look i'm i'm a basic [ __ ] anime fan but
like
you know this avoids tournament arcs
this so it ends it actually ends
instead of going on for you know
five to eight seasons like it's a tight
what 25
and then it's out yeah there's the we
didn't i didn't watch the movie i've
never seen the movie
uh it's got as we say mixed reviews joe
your your thoughts
never seen the movie oh well there you
go uh so
i guess we don't know the true ending um
i if if i i wonder and that they're
already correcting us and ryan they're
probably already correct it's in the
chat but i i'm assuming that the movie
takes place at some point during the
series
as most anime movies do oh it's like the
yeah like the big place in a nebulous
time kind of its own universe where like
they all fight brawley or whatever
yeah um okay uh well yeah i mean the
show's great i don't think
that's like a controversial thing to say
it's just awesome it's just awesome it's
cool
like it's the true definition of cool
like everything about it looks cool
the music is perfect like the whole
thing was scored by the same
uh same artist like doing all that music
and it's just like
impeccable like a version of the 1940s
that i wish
existed musically like it's just so good
yeah if this had come out if cowboy
bebop didn't exist
and like um hbo or someone had dropped
a live-action sci-fi series that was
noir
slash a western like slash j
if someone had done this basically it
would be the biggest tv show of all time
yeah um it just uh you know there's that
there's that weird gate of entry where
people are like cartoons and then that
secondary gate of entry where they're
like
non-american cartoons what
my cartoons like i like my ford trucks
built built for
tiff well let's dive in then to the
honest trailer for
cowboy bebop we will pause when we have
something intelligent to say
so rarely this summer we're getting
honest about summer blockbuster's past
and present we're really stretching
[Music]
in the early 2000s adult swim changed
the animation game
but only one classic anime series made
fans sit up
rub their eyes and say oh i missed
operating hunger force again
uh fine now watch whatever this is
[Music]
oh crap i think i like anime now
cowboy bebop so
i just think that you know as as
gentlemen of a certain age
we'd be remiss if we didn't just stop to
appreciate
the first generation of adult swim
cartoons and how aqua teen
and c-lab uh uh are really as
responsible for
me as anything else that's been made
yeah
yeah um there's something about
that well especially for for me i was
like i was starting college
and um i didn't know anybody and some of
the first friends i made were because
they were like
hey man will come over and watch space
ghost
like cool sounds fun i don't know what
this is um
uh yeah meatball and you know the whole
game
one come on oh my god what did i just do
a little too much when i watch space
ghost oh yeah uh
yeah and then you know for the tenuous
jazz connection my favorite episode of
sealab is when
um the captain gets stuck under the jazz
themed soda machine
and then forms that like parrots that
bond with the
with the scorpion that keeps stinging
him and he gets addicted to venom
oh that's good it's good stuff so after
you're done re-watching cowboy bebop
re-watch
uh the first seasons of c lab which
anyways moving on
max right they're on hbo max i think oh
good uh yeah wherever you can find them
yeah also before we get into this uh
sorry kevin crushed this trailer oh my
god our editor kevin yeah well i was
gonna shout him out when he got to the
custom starring stuff that he
oh yeah yeah we'll give it a go yeah
we'll give him his props um
yeah let's keep going experience a noir
filtered future
where humanity has spread into the solar
system and covered it in hot steamy jazz
where there's so much crime bounty
hunting is part of the gig economy
that attracts only the heaviest
chainsmokers
looks like a plain old moon rock to me
you know hey
how much is it worth if we try to sell
it there are basically uber drivers with
a few more guns
strap in with the paws are they
good bounty hunters not
really right they kind of suck at it
yeah which is
kind of what i love about them because
it really
they're yeah they're not i mean they're
bad asses but
yeah they're not good i think at bounty
hunting and they're really
always hanging in there like at all
times which i think just really adds to
the charm of the story
yeah i mean it the the world they create
is one where like everyone is really
just kind of scraping by um
and it's kind of like uh one might say a
capitalist dystopia where like you're
just
you're working from job to job and
otherwise you're just laying around and
starving
yeah you're either at the high rollers
table in the space casino or you mop the
floors at the space casino
yeah yeah it's so good because they they
just live at like the
the the margins of this society like
even the chain smoking figures in
because they
like each character can't is so hung up
on their own past
like everyone's got the the big shadowy
thing that they can't move on from so
like why wouldn't they smoke they can't
they have no future they're just always
living uh
uh back at that moment of trauma that
they can't move beyond yeah well
i wanted to talk about the smoking too
because it's cool kids it's cool
uh but um uh even
like i love that the show is so aware of
its tropes
uh because it's not until like the end
of the series with mayfaw there
uh she's like the first character that
even acknowledges that everyone's
smoking and i love that the show just
takes its time to be like chain smoking
chain smoking chain smoking i need a
cigarette i need a cigarette i need a
cigarette and then there's this girl
that's just like you smoke inside that's
so gross
it's just so well written yeah uh all
right let's keep going
own mysterious and complex backstories
that you're not gonna get much of
i remember everything really everything
except my own life
there's spike spiegel a mean lean
fighting machine
who also has a literal mean lead
[Music]
nicely valentine
so spike's beagle you know um he's a
combination his
his his uh inspiration was bruce lee
clint eastwood um and and like blade
runner harrison ford and blade runner
which is like a great
great match of protagonists like a
little visual loop in the third
yeah well or yeah loop in the third too
another good one um
but then like i was a little bummed out
because uh
i got excited that we canonically had
our our first uh uh
nice jewish boy anime protagonist you
know
spike's beagle oh spike's here oh
he's a good boy he's such a good boy but
it turned out that his name was
influenced by a
bugsy seagull the uh the mobster um
yeah someday you can't have it all yeah
we're still waiting for uh
for the the maccabee anime star that we
all deserve
let's play a game called who in cowboy
bebop is jewish
they actually did a good job of like i
feel like anime
really uh whitewashing is definitely the
wrong word but like they don't have
different ethnicities or if they do it's
like white people or like
generic flesh tone and then like mr popo
like they don't but this had like good
like
this good mix of uh of like actually
ethnicities that you could
that you could yeah it's weird uh um
of of anything where you're like hey
back in the day
like we'd never make something like that
now or it'd be different now or
like um it's
an interesting conversation to have on a
show
that is riffing on
western tropes uh through a japanese
it's a yeah it's a whole thing
and yeah it's like a post even though
it's riffing on a lot of western stuff
it's like very not american
in the sense that like there's no like
america's gone
in this story there's like there's like
a tijuana and stuff like that but
there's no
you know new york yeah um so i don't
know
it's just interesting a vibrant more
vibrant world than a lot of animes that
you see
yeah no i agree and i love that you
don't get a lot of it
yeah i i you you scrape by
like what they're able to scrape through
and um you know you
here's here's a little bit of titan and
here's a little bit of mars
and ganymede ganymede you hear these
great
um like uh world building lines
you know like uh i i fought with your
father in the clone wars you know stuff
like that you know
like uh uh we're gonna we're gonna get
some money and run away to mars and
you're like oh cool like mars is
awesome like yeah okay but again back
back to why it's so cool is like
a little bit goes a long way explaining
the
clone wars is what got us okay i don't
wanna ignite the prequel debate again
but
like boba fett like the more you know
about boba fett the less crowded it gets
yeah like i don't need to know um i
don't i don't need to know like
uh the city the the like the gridded
like city outline of uh the cities of
the rich cities of mars i just need to
know that like
the idea of mars is like poor people are
like that's that's where i can go to
finally get out of
squalor yeah do we need to know more
about the characters
you'd be the judge um but yeah teach
their own all right keep going
fay valentine who's perpetually broke
if i get rid of my body i won't need
money perpetually leaving
hey wait stay back we're leaving hey
hold on
i have to go and perpetually wedgied
ed a genius also on the toilet all the
time
oh sorry they show around them a lot of
toilets
yeah anyways looks like elmo edward is
edward
ed has never seen this before ed knows
where it is
today it goes looking for the spooky
mysterious alien
i'm very happy to see you i'm
a super intelligent corgi who mostly
just acts like a moderately intelligent
corgi and jet that guy your mom dated
for a while after the divorce
quit complaining and be thankful there's
something to eat
then don't come back there won't be a
place for you good
riddance you're not my real dad i mean
it's perfect
like the the new step dad would be like
an ex-cop who yells at you about the
food that you're not eating
charlie parker you see
kid it's all about the rhythm section
yeah
don't ask him about the arm he freaks
out
he's out about bringing a new guy home
just don't say anything about the arm
don't even look at his arm
um yeah i just uh even everything we
sort of call out in this i think
it speaks to the strength of the writing
this idea that like
uh broken people find each other
because that's kind of you know it's
it's what this is about and they're
will it work will it not we we don't
know because they're they're a powder
keg together that's why phase always
bouncing and
stealing their crap and like jet and
spike are constantly falling out
um i think the only not
broken one is probably ed and i mean i
guess the dog but
yeah i mean to me the common theme was
that everybody has their
uh the past thing that they're hung up
on and they can't move forward until
they've
kind of reconciled it and for ed it was
um their father
uh because you have that whole but what
i loved was ed never actually
seems hung up on anything until
ed comes face to face with the father
stuff yeah towards the end and
then all of a sudden the tractor sort of
changes before it sort of gets
uh smashed in their face like they're
just all over the
all over the map yeah uh but yeah great
cast characters they all
they all work very well together you
guys are 10 out of 10 would watch
keep going together they'll team up to
take on the vicious crime boss
known as vicious occasionally
but mostly they'll be focused on food ed
is hungry
we haven't had anything to eat in two
days i haven't eaten brim or halibut in
a long while
we just came here because there's good
food they ha
i am starving
[Music]
that's all there is
um they might have more money for food
if they didn't smoke like six packs a
day
as cool as smoking is kids it is
expensive it's very expensive
um uh and uh yeah it becomes a lot
harder
after your college campus decides to
stop selling cigarettes and you can't
use your meal plan dollars on them
anymore
wow amazing
very personalized tips you're getting
here
um yeah they uh yeah they're
they got to work on some budget on that
ship because it's you save money from uh
never changing your clothes but that's a
classic animated thing nobody ever
changes clothes
yeah that's an animation thing in
general but you you do save money that
way
um i've i've been wearing these shorts
for eight months
join the club you're still wearing
shorts huh let's go
let's go hunt bounties yeah uh all right
keep going
making a quick move eight million
two point five million sixty three
hundred wulong
five thousand wulongs three hundred
rulings only fifty
wulongs or just kinda hanging out
but no matter the adventure you can bet
that the thing that gets mentioned at
the beginning of the episode will be
super important
i want to be a tough guy like you you
know come on i can do it
and super depressing master
you see it i was fluid like water
yeah don't try to talk anymore hang on
now don't die
don't die wow
that is sad enough to conjure up some
introspective sax music
[Music]
why is saks music it's so cheesy
in a live action context but so cool
when it's in a cartoon it's like
it's like the opposite of putting on a
photo it's like what putting on a fedora
is supposed to be
it just instantly classes it up it's
it is weird right yeah um i i don't know
i think does jazz just get
too pretentious in real life yeah you
need something to balance it with like
uh to cut the jazz pretentiousness
down with a with an action scene or
something like that
or uh or a hyper-intelligent dog
yeah i mean look i'd i'm sure there are
other animes that have jazz in them in
fact there's probably like
an anime that's basically whiplash but
like
they're about different trumpeters uh
surprise
yeah point and it's great but i think uh
this one was it was just like a unique
flavor to me that i never
uh i'd never seen before but it but it's
like chocolate and peanut butter man so
good
yeah no it absolutely works um
uh what was it oh um uh
i'll save it for the end okay uh i guess
this is
the jazz stuff is probably also just
like hey blade runner was cool
[Laughter]
was more a little more synthetic but
yeah yeah no you're you're totally right
leaning into the noir all right let's
keep going
can anyone else hear that or is that
just what my brain sounds like when i
watch the show
so revisit the all-time classic anime
that was probably your gateway drug into
the hard stuff
that clearly uh inspired other shows
about sci-fi outlaws turned family
into junk [ __ ] i've never seen asian and
western aesthetics
that was followed by a movie with mixed
reviews and while they both
might have some all-time great theme
songs only cowboys
is a literal bop story pause
do you think we'll do a firefly honest
trailer one of these days joe
yep all right just checking do you think
uh tennant's gonna come out anytime soon
yeah i guess we don't have any new
movies left we're gonna do a bunch of
weird stuff
that's a good point yeah we're we're
definitely moving into the our favorites
and not the fan favorites
section of uh of media followed by the
oh god what do we do section
yeah huh well what i'm saying is you'll
probably get steven universe in four
months
yeah oh that's okay people seem to like
that one yeah we probably should
yeah all right well let us know in the
comments below
keep going up starring
bed head redemption elita bounty angel
jetblue ed n enbe
dog the bounty hunter so pause
our editor kevin my god he
he's like he's a genius he's
one of the fastest and best editors uh
uh
of all time um please don't hire him or
take him away from us
please don't we need him uh he
he created these custom transitions and
did holtby do the
uh do the textures that's all kevin i
think hope you might have done the text
okay so rob holby does our our uh
what do you call it typography uh custom
custom titles and stuff like that for
everyone
uh and man just went above and beyond to
make this like the intro
and uh it's super cool touches like this
that
just make honest trailers uh it's the
it's the frosting but it's what makes
the cake delicious you know
yeah no i was really excited about this
one anyway and then i saw these
um these uh credits and kind of lost my
mind a little bit just because i was
like oh my god this is great
yeah yeah all right let's keep going
under fee with vendetta illegally blonde
ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
it's better if you leave for today there
are other bounty heads to catch
you don't need this one if you see spike
again
tell him that i'll keep waiting
celebrity cameos
what can tonka guide
because i'm here with my own twin sister
nowadays a 3 8 pneumatic tube isn't in
style anymore enough
miles mono oh boy i think it says
something about uh
what the show creators thought about
western pop culture when they were like
okay what really sums up
let's hear shaft george clooney and the
unabomber
that is that's america for you
and yes very trinity there's the joker's
in there
and yeah yeah
all of our pop culture is is on some
sort of axis closer to george clooney
uh shaft or the unibomb yes um
the best stuff right in the middle
okay keep going he's that's where i met
a cowboy happy hunting all you cowboys
you know what they say cowboy i want a
cowboy you're a cowboy
she's a cowgirl aren't we taking this
cowboy thing a little too far
an actual cowboy see you space cowboy
american healthcare coming up with 30
million rulers for the basic operation
in addition to 54 years of interest
payments 300 million
28 000 wulongs people who believe
instantly in dramatic fantasies who can
be controlled by
tiny dots of light and 2020
nothing good comes from the earth
anymore
blade lounger look at that look at that
cool transition
oh cool great they're making a live
action adaptation of my life story
who's stuck with that job oh nice see a
space cowboy
uh make that see you after you recover
from knee surgery
space cowboy huh doesn't quite have the
same ring to it
all right pause we gotta talk about that
yeah i did not know we were doing that
and uh made a real loud squealy
sound when i heard that cut that is uh
steve blum uh the voice of spike
on the dubs um john the epic voice
himself
uh uh reached out on our behalf
um and it happened like you know late
friday
uh uh last weekend and it was like yeah
he might be interested like
you could maybe pass him something so
like you know you don't put too much
stock in something like that but just in
case
uh rewrote the last joke uh to be coming
from spike instead of instead of john
sent it off didn't expect to hear
anything from it and it came back in
like five minutes before we could have
not used it anymore like it really came
at the 11th hour like oh crap up yep
he's in he's in
uh and uh and there you go it was just
uh
it was like a triple bank shot from john
to like his rep to steve then from steve
to his rep to john to us
and like it all came together at the
last minute how cool is that
little spikes beagle drop yeah that was
awesome yeah i am i
it's weird i i feel like i still
after a couple years of doing this stuff
you know obviously like
working with reynolds and getting to
meet like some like a-listers and stuff
is always
yeah something about you you just drop
you drop you know
one of the names when you're when you're
close just me and clooney
me and reynolds me and cloons you know
just like well you know cloons is the
guy i met watching aquatean hunger for
us in college george clooney was like do
you want to smoke a spliff with me
george clooney and watch the meat man
um but there's just something about like
getting to do stuff with steve blooms
and like
like these like cult favorites that uh i
just
still kind of lose my [ __ ] over yeah we
got one coming up
if we can really pull it off next week
that uh that
uh i would have been really blown away
by
uh had it happened in the in the 90s
but that's the that's the magic we bring
you every day uh
here at honest trailers um i'm glad we
i'm glad we pulled that off
and uh and yeah what what a great voice
you listen i i recommend listen to it
with some cans on because no offense to
john but like he's got some real
resonance in that voice that
or maybe he's just got a really fancy
mic i don't know it sounds really good
like a like a warm saxophone dipped in
honey
yeah it's like a sax lick exactly dipped
in molasses
uh all right cool um
let's see uh oh before so we're gonna
show you some
outtakes but before that i'd like to
call you all to action
i will now thank you for being with us
every day
subscribe to our channel for vids every
weekday
hit that like hit that bell uh that's
part one part two
you guys want uh if you've seen those
hey fandoms we've been doing we've been
doing it with some um
some vo people uh uh the voice of cora
she's on one of them so they're all on
fandom.com backslash
and you can see uh some fun q and a's
with some really cool
uh creative people that have smart
things to say
um well done man and then we're doing uh
we're doing a review this week
of the umbrella academy season one yeah
my voice goes up because i haven't seen
it is that you joe
no you're on the list man you got a real
quick watch umbrella academy
i think me and roth are talking umbrella
academy all right cool well then if you
want to watch joe and roth talk umbrella
academy
um all of your dreams will come true
this friday so catch up on that show
and and check it out um that's that
let's watch
oh oh thank you joe thank you thank you
um
let's watch some outtakes if we have any
yeah
where there's so much crime bounty
hunting is part of the gig economy
complete with its own tv show hi amigos
you ready for some bounty info and atm
machines
thanks for the payoff and while they
both might have some
um i love the sorry just another
thing i love about this show i love the
long game of the bounty hunter show
i love that it just slowly gets more and
more ridiculous
and more and more over the top and more
and more offensive uh
small pause for spoilers and then at the
end of the show
they quit that show and um uh i think
jet walks by the actor and he's just
he's he's he's a completely different
guy
just in a suit like taking care of his
mom and he's like ugh
i can't believe i did like you know a
thousand episodes of that terrible tv
show or something like that like i just
love the the long plays on on the jokes
and
so good yeah the i was reading more
about like the background
of the show and um uh that this was
uh um the genesis of it was from um
oh god i'm gonna get the name wrong it
wasn't funimation but uh
whoever was behind it um was like a toy
company and they're like we need to make
maybe bandai and they're like we need to
make uh anything you can make anything
you want as long as there's cool
spaceships in it that we can make toys
of and he turned in his like his pitch
his proposal and they're like
this nah this isn't like this is too
mature and it kind of just like
languished in development hell until a
different
side of the company that was like more
dedicated to selling like
visual style stuff and like uh
and soundtracks and things like that
like uh picking up into bodybuilders
and body pillows some different aspect
of the kind of the company that wasn't
dedicated to selling toys
uh uh was able to get this into
production so that's why he was given
free reign to have like
adult themes and like uh mature uh
comedy and
like slow burns and things that would
pay off uh way on down the line so
uh just a happy accident that this show
was even allowed to exist in the first
place or that it exists in the form it
does because otherwise it'd be a lot of
um
spaceships that probably turn into other
larger spaceships yeah
and uh commenting on attacks and power
levels uh well thank you to
bandai's uh vinyl and body pillow wing
we wouldn't have this account for so
many things including this show
uh do you have any other delete scenes
and while they both might have some
all-time great theme songs
only cowboys is a literal bob three two
one we're trying not to get uh
monetized by playing that quick thing
yeah all right playing
see baby it's all about the exposition
you don't hear man
starring kung fu hustler
business casual bo buffet
reborn identity i can't take off my
golden arm
ever all right how this works as you can
tell
air bud severoth little dead corvette
ensemble
fistful of wulongs
the same blood runs through both of us
the blood of a beast who wanders
hunting for the blood of others i've
bled all that kind of blood away
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
nobody
we also could have done the garth
meringue dark place uh blood
blood blood blood blood blood bits
and bits of sick all right there is your
uh uh uh deleted scenes now let's get
into comments from viewers
like you uh ryan partlow and carving
light both write
uh joe confirming that the movie is a
mid-season episode so
okay yeah they get a little money they
make a they make a full
uh flashy looking filler app but i'd
still watch it i like more i'd like to
watch more of that
yeah um zoe laird writes
i would like to offer a distant
spiritual successor made by netflix
canon busters a hip hop space cowboy
type anime
i thought it was fun all right i'm
looking for more
stuff that's like uh bebop um i watched
samurai champloo that was cool that kind
of had
the whole chat was hoping you guys had
seen that they were they kept missing
that show a lot
well there you go that was awesome um i
would recommend it as well
if joe hasn't seen it oh yeah no i love
shampoo
um cool so the great thing about bebop
is the more you get old and the more you
like cowboy bebop
series and it jazz music i don't know
but i agree i had that statement yeah
um okay rob turner writes rare serious
question
have you seen outlaw star is that how
serious
look i need to sit you down i have a
question for you
have you seen outlaw star
and if so how do you think this compares
is maybe the more serious half of it i
don't know i've seen
tri-gun that's that's sort of like this
um outlaw star
that sounds so familiar because i think
that was one of the toonami ones right
uh i have taken no i've never seen
outlaw star i have seen most of space
dandy
which is dandy oh you'd like space dandy
it's uh
it's it's like if an honest trailer of
cowboy bebop
was a show all right everyone's saying
space dandy in the chat right now joe
like as you said that so they're right
when i say space chat says dandy's
face dandy well the ship in outlaw star
looks just like the bebop but
we'll have to check that out um matthew
mcguire confirms
i guess regards to bounty hunting no
they absolutely suck at it that's core
to the premise
uh and one quarter it's not just that
they suck at it but it's um
uh they're they're not they're
they're not wired for it they're
constantly trying to make
moral decisions or do the right thing
or like which completely screws them all
the time yeah i think that they
recognize the common
humanity or the common situation that
they find themselves in with their prey
of like
you know they're just on the run and
they have like
uh they have nowhere left to go and like
that's that's them as well
um because spike's a one-man raid the
redemption
but like the fact that he's got uh a
conscience
is what all right and then finally moshu
willow writes i am here for anime
trailers i damn near choked when i saw
the honest trailer today
well don't choke and stick around um i
don't know if we have any like
immediately planned but
i'd do another one i mean these are fun
yeah um
we did eons ago on screen junkies plus
we had anime trailers that we had
no part in save for like taking a look
at the finished product i mean like
thumbs up thumbs down
um but like i think we should probably
take
take a deep dive into into some of your
favorite shows what would you uh what
would you do joe
oh god um i mean uh
miyazaki stuff would be good well we
should do dragon ball
z right i mean yeah i've seen every
episode multiple times
um we should do dragon ball that's yeah
that's probably the first place to go
because that's the most popular and
i know it's basic but like it's also
hilarious i think we i think there'd be
plenty of jokes
yeah yeah i think that's where we start
because cowboy buff is almost too good
to like
really make fun of yeah this was like a
winter soldier level trailer where we're
like this is great
this is cool which which is fine that
should those should exist right
alongside the roast
i think dragon ball z will be a good mix
of both yeah
well settle in for that that's going to
take us a bit but we'll get to it
um and then we'll get to the good stuff
don't worry uh
and that's that that's that for this
week honest trailer commentaries
um come back next week when um
uh we'll be giving you a little more if
that's what you want
um of the same thing so uh
we'll see you then that's your clue and
uh
thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
you